the concept of the underworld is one
that can be found in most religions and
forms of mythology and it's often
guarded by gods and other mythical
creatures today we take a look at
Cerberus the guardian of the underworld
in Greek mythology Cerberus was a
monstrous three-headed hound with a Mane
made from hundreds of snakes a Serpent's
tail and the claws of a lion the three
heads of Cerberus who believes represent
the past the present and the future
there are some different opinions in
regards to the symbolism behind Cerberus
three heads with some believe in the
heads a more symbolic of birth youth and
old age
Cerberus possess the ability to turn
anyone who crossed his gaze into stone
much like Medusa and her Gorgon sisters
with razor sharp teeth and a poisonous
bite not many dared to cross Cerberus
like many of the fiercest monsters in
Greek mythology Cerberus his father was
typhoon the most feared of all of the
monsters and his mother was a kid now
the half woman half snake creature also
known as the mother of all monsters
Cerberus his primary role was to be the
watchdog of the underworld and he was a
loyal servant to his master Hades the
god of the underworld he was chained to
the gates of Hell by Hades but he was
still able to patrol the river Styx and
akram as they were the main way in and
out of the underworld
Cerberus prevented any of the dead
attempting to escape the underworld as
well as the Livan who tried to enter
without the permission of Hades he would
often help guide the dead into the
underworld but savagely attack and
devour those who attempted to leave
Cerberus makes an appearance in several
mythological stories and often he is
shown being bested by the hero one of
these stories features Orpheus a famed
musician in Greek mythology
Orpheus his wife was bitten by a
poisonous snake and she died resulted in
her being sent to the underworld
stricken by grief are no longer able to
play his music he decided he would
attempt to rescue his wife from the
underworld when attempting to cross the
river Styx
Orpheus encountered Cerberus and he
began to play his harp Cerberus was sent
into a deep slumber and Orpheus was able
to cross the river unopposed some of you
may have seen a similar story without
even knowing in JK Rowling's Harry
Potter we see a three-headed dog named
fluffy who closely resembles Cerberus
fluffy is charged with God in the
Philosopher's Stone and similar to the
original myth be sent to sleep with the
music of an enchanted harp Solaris is an
interest in figuring Greek mythology as
dogs were often presented as wild and
rarely shown as domesticated or pets but
Cerberus is shown to be an obedient
servant to Hades I personally feel that
this is one of the main reasons why
Cerberus is shown to be a mixture of
creatures and not just a canine there
seems to be a recurring theme with
canine like creatures or gods being the
Guardian to the underworld we see this
with the god Anubis in Egyptian
mythology the hound known as GaN in
Norse mythology and of course Cerberus
in Roman and Greek mythology is it
possible that this goes back to the
age-old belief that dog is man's best
friend or is this just a mere
coincidence
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained